so next game
from denmark
yes just now the slavic exchange has already
hit the mark i will try again
something so serious
is yes a funny
move the lady can
not move again by the way the 500 runners b 54 o’clock
gone
well actually at night consider
solo 5
there we have it  on 10 6 already pawns
won
at
least the question what do we do now
ok about the quality
can't save the sound now
cost a bit of time
wow i didn't even see it
ok but
i can also change here
insists
the
otherwise has  he now saved the source
but of course it's always just a
bit strange
pawns I already have
more
so
the e7 somehow plays anyway I had runner
c6 there was no clever one
so first advance here again
well that's maybe quite clever
if I swap now  would the
runner no longer have a field
but okay if he swaps himself now
yes i'll let him swap himself
then have  e I have two doubled pawns but
safe control here over the
black squares
but jumped g4 I don't think it's ever that
important because I then have f3 you have to
take two
he knights haven't become a film yet
he could take and then maybe
still a rook of 6b six games
direction b 4
that's maybe a bit
uncomfortable again
maybe we'll have to see
how
thom b4 can also fuel two can
play
him not only do I also
probably have to play
king 3 each then g4 jumps back a
bit strangely
so
I'll play f3
just a moment for sex i can't pull away from you that's
stupid
well ok the f3 if he does now for
six games i can easily play b5
and he then he has to
give up
the doubling the c7 i have bishop 6
so now it looks good
all the figures don't matter anymore
now i can i can i
come forward here
so he was a
yes now i also have the finish line
what should be now  but slowly to be really
really good
so the material was good before
but i
also think that you control the position
so yes i think a do
the tower b60
more black can't exactly
pull much i can also
strengthen it a bit here
and now  simply thoma 8 or
something like that does the organic farmer do the running
i hope
sometime again such an opening is an accident
in slavic exchange yes that's
a bit familiar